I don't want him to feel different he is
different he lifted a tractor with one
finger Martha whoever put him in that
ship had no idea or care for how
dangerous a world they were sending him to
breaking news an unidentified object
heading towards earth was detected by
STAR Labs
Look, up in the sky!
why are you here why are you
here Kryptonian
Lois and you are I'm Clark Kent!
this planet is protected alien
I thought Martians only existed in the
movies those movies are terrible are you
right miss lane what's the S for
Superman
those people are in great danger
let them go
my name is kal-el of Krypton and I come
in peace if they knew about you maybe
they'd see things differently or maybe
the government will lock him up
Superman is trying to let the world know
that by showing the good side of being
an alien that might change people's
minds so for Clark
it's an acceptance of his powers and his
responsibility for the world to share
that with everyone this president knows
a good investment when he sees it
What do you do now you've already taken down
the most powerful man in the world
have I?
I hope fans see this as a new
beginning but I'm really excited to see
not only the new look but these sort of
new performers that are taking on these
voices for the first time you read about
it tomorrow on The Daily Planet I love
you bye! I can't say I'm trying to mimic
or run from any of the guys before I
think inevitably just by being me
hopefully it'll be unique are you alright
miss lane as much of a responsibility as
it is it's so also fun to be able to
play a character everybody knows I love
dipping into these worlds that are so
established and so fully realized
that we get to take it in new directions I
I hope people see the movie they feel like
we have done justice to Superman that
they feel like we've reintroduced him in
a way that is faithful to what we know
and what we love about the character for
goodness in it
he's Superman and he's the
Superman you love you were right
this was the fun way
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Superman movie
trailers Superman man of tomorrow so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want them to do
with the new rebooted animated movie
universe I will explain what's going on
with that because they just rebooted the
entire continuity of the animated movie
universe was Justice League apocalypse
war a little while ago but just talking
about the footage first explaining
what's going on with this movie if you
have no idea what's going on this is
essentially a retelling of Superman's
origin story based on the man of
tomorrow storyline they have all new
voiceover actors playing all the major
characters like Darren Criss is playing
Superman
alexandra daddario is playing lois lane
and you have Zachary Quinto playing Lex
Luthor I wasn't a big fan of the Rainn
Wilson Lex Luthor even though I do like
rain Wilson's work his comedy work I
wasn't a big fan of his version of Lex
Luthor for the most part this movie just
chronicles his entire early history so
he crash-lands the pot on earth
everybody knows the Superman origin
story he's found by the Kent's he's
raised as you see through the trailer he
sort of beta tests the early versions of
his costume as he learns about his
powers he goes through the standard
montage then his early encounters with
Lex Luthor a younger version of Lex
Luthor and then an older version later
because it jumps forward in the timeline
him slowly developing the Superman
persona through his debuted the full
costume for the first time there are a
couple of his comic book villains that
he fights along his way along his
journey to becoming Superman
you see parasite obviously Lex Luthor
then you see Lobo they're kind of using
Lobo in the movie is a sort of Dark
Mirror as the way the world might view
Superman darkest timeline does dangerous
alien come to wreak habit and do as he
pleases and no one's powerful enough to
stop him but it's Superman proving them
all wrong you're not wrong about me
earning their trust showing them that
he's more human than most of the humans
that live on earth if you remember
Doomsday Clock with Superman versus dr.
Manhattan that was essentially the theme
of that comic book was Superman
reminding dr. Manhattan what it means to
be human because dr. Manhattan as a
character in The Watchmen series
effectively becomes so powerful that he
loses all connection with earth and
humans I always loved watching Superman
power montages they did it on
Pawel back in the day i'm sure they'll
do a version of it on the new superman
TV show the live-action TV show that's
going to start next year because they have
a couple of versions of Superboy they're
going to be a high-school-aged so they'll
probably be figuring out about their
powers then too one of the things that
people get wrong about why the Sun makes
him powerful is that it's not so much
the presence of the Sun or him being
line of sight with the Yellow Sun that
makes him powerful is the specific solar
radiation given off by the Yellow Sun in
the cosmic rays the given power so you
don't actually need the Yellow Sun to
power him up you just need stored solar
radiation to juice him and he's good to
go
and the reason why Superman heals so
much faster juice is so much faster in
outer space is because Earth's ozone
layer blocks the majority of harmful
solar radiation for humans but it's
actually good for Superman so he needs
more solar radiation so when he's
outside Earth's atmosphere he just gets
the full dose of cosmic rays they kind
of did a version of that during Batman V
Superman when he was fighting doomsday
he almost dies with that nuclear blast
up in outer space but because he's in
outer space he gets the full dose of
cosmic rays from the Sun and heals way
way faster if you look in the background
to some of these trailer shots to some
of the buildings in the design the art
style looks a little reminiscent of
Superman the animated series that Bruce
Timm did alongside Batman the Animated
Series back in the 90s so some of this
does look like it's inspired by some of
the classic cartoons you also probably
notice the liberal use of 3d and
computer animation most of the animation
industry has moved in some fashion to 3d
animation over 2d animation even though
Justice League apocalypse war was 2d
mostly they did use a lot of 3d during
that in 3d used properly is actually
capable of looking good but the big
problem that a lot of animated series
run into is that they either overuse it
or they use it poorly so it just winds
up looking bad compared to 2d animation
but obviously this is the reboot that
they were talking about when they were
talking about rebooting the animated
universe with apocalypse war in that big
flashpoint at the end
so here's quick explainer for why they
did that and why they used apocalypse
war to end that previous line of
continuity DC makes a lot of animated
movies but most of them the last 10
years or so we're all in the same line
of continuity with the same voiceover
actors playing the same major characters
for the most part that all started with
the Justice
sleek flashpoint movie that sort of set
off the new line of continuity then you
have Justice League war then up to the
death of Superman the reign of Superman
and then more recently Justice League
apocalypse war so it's been so long
since they started that they just felt
like it was time to go with the new art
style they wanted to go with new
voiceover actors so they used apocalypse
war to create another flashpoint event
to quote-unquote reboot or rebirth big
DC rebirth Easter Egg the entire DC
Animated universe and explained while
the voiceover actors sound different why
the art style is different and maybe
hopefully if we're lucky they will do
some animated movies based on DC rebirth
because it just feels like an easy slam
dunk the next really big animated movie
the DC announced is actually Batman the
long Halloween which seems weird that
they haven't done a movie based on the
long Halloween before because it's one
of the more famous recent Batman comics
in the last 20 years and obviously I've
been doing a lot of live-action Batman
movie videos recently because they
announced that Michael Keaton would be
coming back as his 1989 Batman from the
Tim Burton movies into the new Justice
League crossover movies the flash
flashpoint movie with Ezra Miller is
going to be the first one that he appears
in as Batman I'll link all those videos
that I just did about that at the end of
this but the Batman movie that's coming
out next year with Robert Pattinson that
Matt Reeves is making is actually
partially based on the long Halloween
story so it is kind of funny that they
have a long Halloween movie coming out
next year but they also have another
Batman movie based on the long Halloween
and I haven't seen any kind of art
stills or previews of what it's actually
going to look like so everyone just let
me know in the comments what do you
think of this new animated style for the
new DC movies and which other DC stories
do you want them to adapt in the movies
congratulations Matt be is 606
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big DC video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details everyone click here
to learn all about Michael Keaton's
Batman coming back for new DC movies and
click here for my Justice League
apocalypse war ending and end credits
scene video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!